and that you left school at 14. yeah and
then just yeah I was going to high
school for like two months you're just
like I can't I'm done oh it's the
stupidest waste of time wow yeah you're
not advocating not graduating high
school though absolutely really a lot of
time uh there's this weird uh conflating
of a high school diploma with a path of
success it makes literally no sense
locking
but taking someone who's 14 and saying
go into an institutionalized learning
facility which will give give you no
real world life skills for four years
talk about wasting formative years what
I did I was programming websites I was
doing Flash animation I was making video
games I was playing music I was
traveling I was skateboarding traveling
around the the area of the city meeting
people and expanding my horizons while
my friends were locked in a box learning
for the fifth year
it's not like I I can't even tell you
they learned anything because the the
reason why I was like I'm done with this
I remember going to a high school math
class we'll call it teacher walks in she
goes uh to turn to page 17 and do those
problems and then walks out of the room
and then we're all sitting around like
what just happened
yes every single math class was that and
I'm like okay and my favorite was um
sitting in a room in English class and
having someone go the the teacher says
all right everyone turn to page 47 and
we're going to read the story for Mark
Twain and I'm sitting there and then uh
Jeremy can you read the answer
inside
encyclopedia
today junior yeah and so I'm just like
bro I could read this whole thing in 10
seconds what am I doing here this is
wasting my time so I I'll just stop to
go I'm out were you living with your
parents at the time yes with my mom my
parents were split up
and then uh actually what happened was
I'm 14 and they did this weird thing
where they changed our schedule from in
grade school it was 7 30 a.m to 2 30 p.m
then they decided for freshman year at
the local high school we're going to do
10 45 a.m to like 5 30 p.m and a lot of
parents were upset they were like this
means that in Winter 14 year old kids
are going to be leaving High School in
the dark like that's crazy and so it was
it was like a a kind of a cultural shock
for me at 14 because you'd get out of
school at 2 30 you go to the park you'd
hang out with your friends you'd come
home it's 2 30 of the whole day ahead of
you school got it now it's like I wake
up at six in the morning because that's
what the schedule always had been my
entire life
and but now I said I'm sitting in my
living room with my hands on my knees
like I'm daytime TV People's Court is on
what am I supposed to do with this get
to school at 10 45 get out at six and
it's time for dinner time for bed and so
it was ridiculously stressful and then
after two months of
insane nonsense not learning a damn
thing I'm 14. I'm halfway to school and
I just sit down in the grass I started
crying and then I got up and turned
around went home called my mom and said
I'm not going to school anymore what'd
you say she I think I can't really
remember I think she said okay
I went from being a straight A student
to a straight F student from grade
school to high school and so my parents
were already like something's not
happening what changed during that time
like did you have a life-changing event
a bad breakup were you smoking weed were
you hanging out with some crowd were you
reading the new book were you uh into
something or no no really no uh in my
life I've smoked wait a handful of times
it just doesn't do anything for me uh it
wasn't hanging out the bad crowd
uh playing music but I think the big
issue was
I I I'm since I was a little kid my
family's had computers I built my first
computer when I was probably seven or
eight years old it sounds impressive to
the average person but it's like I went
to a thrift store bought five pieces and
stuck them together like Legos it's not
the craziest thing in the world
installed Windows on it so my family's
got CompuServe we've got AOL I'm online
I'm reading about the president I'm
reading about I'm reading about the
world this is Clinton at this point or
bush this was I think I think this was
Bush yeah this is this is shortly after
9 11 I think yeah I think so I think I
was 14 it's shortly after so I'm reading
all this stuff online about what's going
on not a whole lot but I'm uh I was I
was Pro I was uh programming things in
Flash I was making websites I was
skateboarding in my life I'm doing all
these things that every day was
improving learning how to use Flash to
make a website and everyone's like wow
you made a website making an animation
where I mean the crude flash animations
like newgrounds.com stuff but every day
I could see something more I started
programming video game within you know
five days I've made a rudimentary video
game that's kind of like Mario Bros a
platformer where you play a little guy
running through a Factory and there's
little monsters and stuff these are
things that were tangible that I could
see were were being completed
then I go to school and they're tying my
hands together and saying sit down shut
up and do nothing and it was it's like
being locked in prison and So eventually
I was just like I'm not doing this it's
it's I'm done you have kids not no when
you have kids you're gonna send them to
high school
probably not no probably not I mean uh
I'm like I'm gonna homeschool I plan on
having kids uh but they're going to be
home schooled
um probably some kind of local pod
learning thing you want kids to
socialize with each other but I think
kids should be learning from adults not
from kids and I think one of the biggest
things that we do today as a society is
we have children learn from each other
we separate kids from their parents like
cows and calves then we put the kids in
a box where they don't care for the
teacher and the teacher doesn't care for
them and then all of their social
interactions are predicated upon other
kids the behaviors of other kids when I
was growing up my family at a coffee
shop all of my social interactions are
with people in their 30s who are buying
coffee and complaining about Republicans
Or democrats yeah so here I am I'm 10
years old and I like all I want to do is
buy Pokemon when it comes out and I'm
trying to save it for the tip jar but
when I'm sitting there the conversation
isn't did you hear what Billy said about
you know Power Rangers it's did you see
what policy was passed I can't believe
they're doing this and that's the stuff
I'm absorbing the behaviors I'm learning
from are adults in in semi-professional
settings they're at the coffee shop
they're writing their work working or
they're playing music my mom's showing
me how to manage the business and the
finances then I go back to this this is
I'm like I'm like sixth or seventh grade
and all of the kids are imitating each
other so what's going to happen when
these kids grow up well I I'm not
surprised to find that
I'm running a business and most of my
friends are
just
working regular jobs they've they've not
gone I'm not saying it's a bad thing
that everyone has to do it I'm saying
don't be surprised if
you take a kid you put them in an
environment where they learn how
businesses work and businesses run and
when they grow up they're doing those
things you plant the seeds those seeds
will grow
Pat your similar story right well not 14
but there's a part of what he's talking
about that you know he's got a very big
a good point I mean what we don't know
about is the following Tim Howard are
you 86 is what so you're 30 okay so we
don't know what it is to be 14 today
let's think about it we don't know what
it is to be 14 today and how you're fed
stuff and you know how you view the
world when you're talking about you know
you're you're in high school and you're
going through it and you know we we were
at AOL chat like I'm thinking 1994 was
AOL chat if a guy was on if a friend of
you was on ale chat hey meet me in this
room and you would go and I was like oh
my God turn on the old Chad you wait
like a couple minutes so things in
journalism is changing in in a very
different way think about today's Temple
Tim at 14 years old today what is that
kid doing today what is he what route is
he taking what what's pissing him off
what journey is he going to be going
through we're 20 years from now the next
Temple you're sitting and he's telling
us about what it's like to be 14 in 2023
and we have to sit there and watch it I
got an 11 year old nine-year-old
six-year-old
and a almost two-year-old in a month and
I I talked to them and ask them so what
what do you learn in school about uh
politics what do you think about this
what do you think about that and with
Tico he can have a full-blown
conversation with you at 11. yeah he and
he wants to have that conversation Dylan
wants to talk Patrick Mahomes Zillow
wants to talk sports he's a sports guy
but it's going to be interesting to see
what happens next 20 years with us so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]